let's admit it America we miss Barack
Obama wanda's mmm there he is in a
recent speech he said he had no real
scandals in his White House a jab at
Trump so to quote the TSA officer whose
dog just sniffed my carry-on let's
unpack this so why didn't you hear much
about OHS White House well who was brave
enough to look there was never a cozier
relationship between a president and the
media ever if the White House were a bed
the press was the mutt dozing at the
foot of it thank God Obama didn't heat
it classic so the media voluntarily took
an 8 years sleeping pill with his liver
snap
only to wake up when Obama's policies
led to the rejection of his party in the
election of Trump then no longer Obama
toast they sprung to action and it
wasn't like there were no scandals under
Obama DOJ IRS Benghazi the media's bar
was so high in terms of interest however
they didn't exist so now you have a woke
press chasing down any incident where
Trump has a burger whose center is in
hot pink now the funny part is Obama's
speech was at a conference where
participants were ejected if they shared
any part of it so you want to know why
you never heard about Obama there's your
answer
compliance compare that to Trump's White
House the most transparent entity since
the invention of scotch tape and still
the press scrambles after him as if
they're making up for lost time it's
like watching a fat man climb a mountain
after a lifetime of couch surfing and
pizza
no wonder they want a Democrat in 2020
they could use the rest isn't it true
Dana that Obama's lack of scandals we're
not about scandals but a compliant press
that allowed him to operate in total
secrecy well having been a Republican
press secretary I would say yes
Republican communicators always have to
work harder yes that is true but I also
think one of the things Oh bomber said
is there were no scandals
that embarrassed us but if you're not
capable of embarrassment then that would
be
a true the other thing is that it is
true that there is less drama yes okay
there was less drama in the Obama
administration if you're looking at sort
of personnel announcements and the
backbiting in the first eight months of
the Trump administration but drama isn't
necessarily a scandal exactly the other
thing unless it's scandal that's good
the other thing is that all of the Obama
camp eople that works for him they have
said this from the beginning
even as he ended his presidency the one
thing they were so proud of is that they
had no scandals and it's because it
became a rote talking point yeah no
scandals is the new no collusion
everybody says it over and over again as
if this is like going to finally sink
into all of our heads mm-hmm
yo Jesse I remember especially MSNBC if
you did criticize President Obama you
were racist yeah so that was a really
good immune bubble to keep any criticism
or anybody from actually looking into
anything going on it's very effective I
think you glossed over a pretty big
Obama scandal Greg what's the birth
certificate I mean that was huge that
lobbyist who was a forgery believe it's
real I think you're right though it's
all about the press because this is what
the press said about Benghazi it was a
Republican conspiracy they didn't
protect one of their own ambassadors on
the anniversary of 9/11 after warning
signs then lied about it and that's a
Republican conspiracy they said the IRS
scandal was bipartisan
even though 95% of the groups that were
targeted were conservative they said the
Iran deal was great diplomacy when we
shipped them a bunch of cash that wound
up in Hezbollah's hands and then they
said about fast and furious that
happened under the Bush administration
even though it absolutely did not so
we're even passing over Solyndra we're
passing over Bergdahl trade Solyndra
half a billion dollars in taxpayer money
the VA scandal
people died and government bureaucrats
got bonuses so I found a list of what
the New York Times says our Trump
scandals are you ready for these okay
Killian Conway promoted Ivanka's fashion
line on TV
government officials stayed in Trump
hotels if that's the bar I mean come on
anything's a scandal you know that's a
good point I forgot about the VA and
Solyndra we did like muscle into us like
a soap opera you Solyndra flashback yeah
you know what I learned from President
Obama my life would be easier if I was a
liberal cuz no one questions your
competence right is that right yes I
should be a liberal you should be my
life would be easier well you'd have a
hard time here at Fox think that Fox was
absolutely vigorous in pursuing every
Benghazi IRS very balanced we had to Oh
fine that's why it's legit but I'm just
saying you say oh that's a scant let me
tell you there's a difference between
nitpicking pimples and stumbling and a
huge rock falling on your head and
crushing you yeah and that rock is 19
people indicted including 13 Russians
right that's five people who've been
tied guilty security adviser who says
he's lie how about Trump in the oval
office talking to Russians about
national secrets oh good about Reverend
tell you what's going on you know I
still don't know what happened in Niger
you talk about Benghazi I'm Niger we got
four people dead no report yet nothing
I'm thinking to myself you are you're
dealing with Class B with somehow you
know how about Rob Porter and beating up
wives oh yeah you can stay the old boy
imagine if that was the imagine if Obama
was paying had his personal lawyer
paying off porn stars oh my god that
would be impressive
last word to you Michelle wouldn't
interesting actually for a lot of
reasons pardon
yes last word team so I think I think
that is important that you have to cover
all that we're covering the Muller
investigation we're covering FISA
warrants how they were obtained the
propriety of it the ethics behind it the
facts and substance behind it so when
you see what we did here we covered
everything in a healthy way
whether it was Solyndra whether it was
Ben Ghazi whether it was fast and
furious whether it was Lois Lerner and
attack isn't all of the above there was
a plethora of things that needed to be
discussed and so I wouldn't take back
any of it I would in fact do it the way
we did it mm-hmm
damn straight Oh